breanne starts off this hour in Oregon
hi Brianne
how are you hey great thank you so much
for taking my call I'm a huge fan
my pleasure how can I help so we'll give
you a little backstory my husband and my
two little girls and we both have great
jobs although he's a farmer which means
he's extremely frugal and his profession
is kind of a gamble and but we live in a
very very very small town where housing
options are very rare a house will open
up once every like four years and so
we've been really good with our finances
I'm a planner and motivated I was also
the spender until I realized that my
husband's love language was financial
security and so I kind of cooled it and
I decided to be competitive with myself
and get on track and be debt-free and
everything we have everything on the
list the steps baby steps except one
thing and I could pay off my car today
which is the easy answer pay off my car
but because we live in a community
that's so small with housing that rarely
opens up I've been very hesitant to in
case a rare opportunity knocks and then
we didn't have the downpayment as big as
I'd like so I'm kind of in this battle
going back and forth back and forth of
just pay it off and have faith that that
it will something will open up or or
knowing I can pay it off we'll have it
paid off in about five months so if we
don't just pay it off today so I'm just
going to turn what to do because we
don't it's not like houses there's like
five houses on the market all the time I
want to be able to invest in a house as
soon as the the cars paid off as soon as
opportunity knocks we tell you not to
buy real estate until you're dead free I
mean so it I guess we could be dead for
you today
finish laughs you're following our plan
you can't buy a house because you have a
car payment yeah so no matter what just
pay it off and then I will never I would
never buy a house until you were debt
free okay so it would be necessary to
get it free in order to buy
right which I could do tomorrow I just
was scared that if something opened up
and I wouldn't have an opportunity to
invest I uh hurry but the premise that
you're basing that on is you're gonna
buy a house just to have a car payment
and I'm not gonna go well I'll tell you
do that I think that's dumb okay even if
housing opened up is here here's the
thing the blessings of the Lord have no
sorrow added to them and when you buy
stuff you can't afford because you're
still sitting on car payment you're
still sitting over there with nothing it
doesn't turn out to be a blessing it
turns out to be a curse and so if the
house if the house opened up I would not
call that God yeah because you're not
ready to buy is it right because let me
make it afford a house am i right now
and the car but I just do want
autonomous conversation doesn't you know
I I get what you're saying I just think
the nervous is just the lack of animals
but you just told Dave I am too you can
still afford a car payment and the house
payment together after I just told you
that I know okay you're right I'm sorry
stop it get out of that kiddo we got out
of that little hole you're gonna listen
and nothing else go buy your piece of
ground build your house well that's the
problem there's nothing to build in our
area there's nothing there's so small
there's no options there's no land yeah
even the farmland we bought on the
business side you can't there's not
enough to break off there's no it's
really small it's frustrating there's no
land in your area to build a house
they'll come Ron seriously okay if you
if you have to build an impossible
fatalistic model in order to go do
something stupid then you know that
that's what's gonna happen so no you're
going to get a house just fine pay off
your car